madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
plus que 2h15 et ce sera peut-être
l'explosion en général en corse une
explosion tout pacifique puisque elle
signifiera que le football club de
bastia aura réussi dans sa tentative de
devenir finaliste de la coupe de l'uefa
dans 30 minutes au stade furiani de
bastia les corses vont affronter le
grasshopper de zurich les tribunes sont
déjà comble vous le constater sur ces
images
tous les spectateurs et tous les
téléspectateurs d'antenne 2 n'attendent
qu'une chose ce soir une victoire des
joueurs de pierre cahuzac thierry roland
comment se présente cette demi finale
est bien finale se présente bien
l'ambiance à bastia et survolté comme
vous venez de le dire
malheureusement il a plu une bonne
partie de la dernière nuit pleuvait
emporte matin de bonne heure et la
pelouse gelée du mythe gorgée d'eau par
endroits il ya des plaques doha par an
et le match se déroulera certainement
dans des conditions difficiles mais tout
un peuple que dit toute une île tout le
football français derrière le sporting
de bastia pour réussir après le tap de
rein est teinté tienne l'exploit que
l'on jugeait impossible en début de
saison parvenir en finale de la coupe de
l'uefa et croyez le bien
les joueurs en sont conscients et prêts
à donner dans une vingtaine de minutes
maintenant le meilleur d'eux-mêmes de
vue de ce match en effet à 20h30 ce
journal sera donc un tout petit peu plus
court que d'habitude alpha ne pas rater
une seule seconde de cette demi-finale
bastia jury qu il s'appelait joseph
delteil en 1925 il avait obtenu le prix
femina pour un livre intitulé jeanne
d'arc mais joseph delteil c'était aussi
un autre personnage une sorte de hippies
du début du siècle un homme hors du
temps impertinente dans son attitude
explosifs dans son expression
à 84 ans ce surréaliste des années 20
qui avait rompu avec le mouvement
d'andré breton disparaît c'était l'un
des hommes les plus surprenants de notre
époque
le divorce entre l'homme et la nature
est dangereux et même mortelles pour
l'humanité écrivait joseph delteil au
début du siècle
prêchant par l'exemple il quitte à paris
à 40 ans en pleine gloire littéraire
son premier roman sur le fleuve amour
avait eu un grand succès et sa jeanne
d'arc avait obtenu le prix femina
c'est sa rencontre avec sa femme
caroline du de l'est qui révéla
joséphine backert aux français qui
pousse à joseph delteil à fuir paris et
ses fréquentations pourtant illustre
dans sa campagne languedocienne il
continue à écrire abondamment et se
mettre de la langue française
l'expression et d'henri muller oublié de
1937 à 1960 et redécouvert par la
jeunesse
après la publication de ses oeuvres
complètes son dernier livre sacré cor
publié en soixante seize est un retour à
l'enfance et à ce pays cathare donc il
était si fier j'ai l'impression que ce
que j'écris de n'a pas tellement collé
avec l'époque que j'ai vécu c'est
l'impression que de plus en plus ce que
j'écris ce vin dans la ligne du de la
jeunesse futur j'ai quitté paris à ces
cas où je crois et c'est pas tout
j'étais je n'ai jamais été à ma place à
ma fonction et j'ai toujours eu besoin
là tout seul comme si c'était seul au
monde est en réalité la plupart de mes
livres je t'écris et dans ce sens comme
s'ils étaient seuls au monde et comme si
je n'avais pas besoin de communiquer
avec mes semblables
je ne suis pas né comme vous d'une maman
qui est d'un papa est dans un milieu qui
m'a appris ma leçon n'est pas
actuellement quand un enfant d on le
pensait chez nous et on commence à lui
et suce les jours à jour mot-à-mot tout
ce qu'il ya à faire dans toute sa vie
comme s'ils n'avaient pas ou vivre sa
vie le même estate que possède toutes
les bêtes toutes les zones tous les
animaux insectes un ronald ne les phares
c'est un message qui l'appelle il ne va
pas à l'école il n'a pas besoin
d'institutions pourquoi seul nom n'est
besoin de quelqu'un qui lui dit mot à
mot ce qu'il a à peine dans la vie dans
la vie ce qu'il a fait c'est de respirer
doubler les yeux de jouir du monde de
s'amuser et de remplir et sa vie à achat
certaines des images que vous venez de
voir sont extraites d'un film réalisé il
ya quelques années par jean marie drot
un film que vous pourrez revoir les 17
et 24 avril les deux prochains lundi à
21h30 antenne 2 présentera en effet un
hommage à joseph delteil
cet hommage sera ce film dans son
intégralité ils étaient tous là ce matin
à l'elysée tous les ministres mais aussi
les secrétaires d'état pour la première
réunion au grand complet du nouveau
gouvernement barre un conseil des
ministres à l'ordre du jour assez peu
chargé une mise en route en quelque
sorte un projet de loi à tous même été
adoptée projet qui fera plaisir à tous
ceux que la publicité énerve ou agace le
gouvernement a décidé une réglementation
de la publicité
en résumé le projet vise à
l'interdiction de l'affichage partout où
cet affichage est gênant c'est à dire en
dehors des agglomérations sur les
monuments ou dans les sites prestigieux
jusqu'à présent la loi de 1943 qui
réglemente la publicité est bafouée
violées chaque jour c'est donc à cause
de cette anarchie que depuis sept ans on
travaille à une nouvelle loi qui devrait
enfin assurer une réelle protection des
sites dans les agglomérations toute
publicité sera interdite dans les lieux
les plus prestigieux
la publicité sur les véhicules dans les
airs
ainsi que le mobilier urbain seront très
sévèrement contrôlés en dehors des
agglomérations l'affichage sera tout
simplement interdit le pouvoir des
maires doit être étendue ils pourront
s'ils le désirent rendre la loi plus
restrictive
enfin en cas d'infraction des amendes
dissuasives décourageront les fraudeurs
et les associations pourront se porter
partie civile
il était grand temps de tirer le signal
d'alarmé de la signalisation
le premier acte de ce gouvernement et
vous voyez que c'est un acte de
décentralisation des responsabilités et
en même temps de réponse à des
aspirations de la population et
protection notre patrimoine et nos
paysages
en dehors de l'étude de ce projet de loi
sur la publicité il était aussi question
ce matin lors du conseil des ministres
du marché commun c'est ainsi que
monsieur giscard d'estaing a insisté sur
le caractère positif du récent sommet de
copenhague
monsieur raymond barre après la réunion
du conseil a donné cet après midi le
coup d'envoi de ces rencontres avec les
dirigeants syndicaux
en un peu moins de trois semaines le
premier ministre va recevoir les
représentants des grandes centrales
syndicales mais aussi ceux du patronat
et des petites et moyennes entreprises
le premier à être reçu aujourd'hui
c'était monsieur andré bergeron au nom
de fo
nous avons demandé que les négociations
s'engagent rapidement dans la fonction
publique et dans les entreprises
nationales où il n'existe pas encore
d'accord
ces négociations vont s'engager dans les
semaines qui viennent je ne peut
naturellement pas dire si elles
déboucheront sur des compromis
acceptable par les organisations force
ouvrière mais enfin
nos organisations participant aux
négociations avec la volonté de parvenir
à des accords qui préserve les intérêts
des gens que nous représentons
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'il
n'ya vraiment un déblocage dans la
négociation sociale
écoutez c'est encore trop tôt pour le
dire les négociations vont s'engager
c'est à ce moment là que nous pourront
porter jugement
mais encore une fois nous irons à ces
négociations avec une volonté d'aboutir
sans démagogie sans surenchère en tenant
compte des réalités dans notre
environnement
mais naturellement des intérêts des gens
que nous représentons
du côté du gouvernement on souligne
voir aussi le très bon climat dans
lequel s'est déroulée cette rencontre
avec le leader de force ouvrière maison
précise également que monsieur raymond
barre n'annoncera pas ses intentions
dans le domaine social avant la fin de
ses consultations avec l'ensemble des
syndicats et du patronat
une attitude qui est d'ailleurs celle
aussi du patronat français monsieur
françois ceyrac le soulignait ce matin
dans une interview il n'est pas question
que le patronat s'engage avant de
connaître les intentions du gouvernement
déclaré t-il il n'en demeure pas moins
que pour le cnpf 3 problème devrait être
résolu très rapidement le problème des
bas salaires tout d'abord celui de
l'emploi donc du chômage
ensuite et enfin le problème de
l'aménagement du temps de travail d'un
côté comme de l'autre on s'oriente donc
vers une reprise et une progression de
ce que l'on a appelé au début des années
70 la politique contractuelle une
politique qui reste le cheval de
bataille des syndicats réformistes
encore faut-il pouvoir la mettre en
oeuvre et la faire aussi coïncidé avec
les impératifs économiques du bon andré
bergeron le rappelait la politique
contractuelle
c'est d'abord une table et puis autour
de cette table des représentants du
patronat et des syndicats
depuis dix ans les habitudes sont
tellement prise que dans la grande salle
du cnpf où les délégations se réunissent
régulièrement les uns et les autres
occupent toujours la même place pour
parler de quoi
et bien de tout ce qui concerne la
protection sociale des travailleurs un
domaine extrêmement vaste qui va des
congés payés aux allocations de chômage
en passant par les conditions de travail
ou les systèmes de retraite
complémentaire mais avec toujours le
même principe fondamental les accords
signés
après ces négociations ou quasiment
force de loi pour les parties prenantes
c'est en 1969 le gouvernement chaban
delmas que cette politique connu son
véritable essor avec la signature des
contrats de progrès dans les entreprises
nationalisées
ces contrats fixait les règles
d'augmentation des rémunérations ainsi
que les modifications des grilles de
salaires et avaient pour objectif
créer la paix sociale dans l'entreprise
sous cette impulsion les patrons et les
syndicats du secteur privé décidèrent de
négocier entre eux tout un ensemble de
problèmes en disant ils ont ainsi entre
autrement l'accord fixé le calendrier de
la mensualisation les règles de la
formation permanente la garantie de
ressources pour les salariés de plus de
60 ans et les 90% d'indemnités en cas de
licenciement économique
cette politique contractuelle ne se
limite pas à des négociations niveau
national elle prévoit également que
soient négociés au sein des branches ou
des entreprises des accords portant sur
des problèmes spécifiques et c'est ainsi
que depuis 1972
chaque année 3000 accords furent signés
depuis deux ans la politique
contractuelle a connu un fort
ralentissement
l'éventualité d'un changement politique
rendait moins impérative pour les
syndicats
une concertation régulière dans le
secteur public les contrats de progrès
étaient renouvelés sans être vraiment
négocier et dans le secteur privé les
liens étaient certes maintenu mais les
grands thèmes n'était pas abordé
voilà pour les affaires sociales retour
au conseil des ministres car le conseil
ce matin a aussi adopté un certain
nombre de décrets qui fixe les
attributions des ministres du nouveau
gouvernement de monsieur raymond barre
il s'agissait essentiellement de
partager les tâches entre le ministre de
l'économie
monsieur rené monory et le ministre du
budget monsieur papon qui contrôleront
chacun une partie de ce que l'on a
appelé le bastion de la rue de rivoli
c'est à dire le bastion des finances à
bastien que monsieur raymond barre et
monsieur giscard d'estaing ont fait
éclater en formant le nouveau
gouvernement le ministre de l'économie
c'est à dire monsieur rené monory a donc
sous son autorité maintenant la
direction à les services responsables de
l' équilibre économique et monétaire
c'est-à-dire le trésor les prévisions
les relations économiques extérieures la
concurrence et les prix les assurances
les statistiques et les études
économiques
de son côté le ministre du budget c'est
à dire monsieur pape on rassemble les
secteurs responsables de l' équilibre
des recettes et des dépenses le budget
bien sûr de l'état c'est-à-dire le
budget la comptabilité publique les
impôts c'est le plus important pour vous
comme pour moi la législation fiscale la
douane
et les droits indirects les deux
ministres disposeront conjointement de
l'inspection générale des finances de la
direction générale pour les relations
avec le public et de la direction du
personnel et des services généraux
voilà pour le conseil enfin sur l'agenda
de cette journée il y avait aussi un
déjeuner ce midi à l'elysée le chef de
l'état monsieur giscard d'estaing a reçu
plusieurs personnalités il s'agissait
des présidents des différentes
assemblées et aussi du président du
conseil constitutionnel
messieurs chaban-delmas poher vente jol
pour le conseil économique et social et
monsieur roger frey pour le conseil
constitutionnel était donc présent en
tout cas ni lors de la réunion du
gouvernement ni lors de ce déjeuner à
l'elysée il a été officiellement
question de la présentation au parlement
du programme gouvernemental il est
cependant probable que monsieur raymond
barre le 19 avril prochain demandera à
l'assemblée nationale de voter la
confiance sur un programme de politique
générale plusieurs responsables de l'udf
se sont déclarés ces derniers jours
favorables 1 vote des députés
et on pense aussi que le rpr de son côté
voterai pour ce programme gouvernemental
si cela lui était demandé un nouveau
gouvernement doit-il nécessairement
poser la question de confiance à
l'occasion d'une déclaration de
politique générale c'est une vieille
controverse pour l'opposition ou pas
d'hésitation c'est là une obligation par
contre pour la majorité
chaque gouvernement doit être libre de
décider en conseil des ministres s'il
est opportun ou non d'engager sa
responsabilité si le gouvernement ne
pose pas la question de confiance et
l'opposition qui prend l'initiative elle
dépose ou non une motion de censure elle
doit faire ainsi la preuve qu'elle est
capable ou non de constituer une autre
majorité dans ce cas seul vote les
députés qui veulent effectivement
renverser le gouvernement
si en revanche le premier ministre pose
la question de confiance
tous les députés sont appelés à se
prononcer et chacun d'entre eux doit
dire clairement par son vote s'il
soutient ou non le gouvernement dans la
situation actuelle
monsieur bart n'a pas besoin de
démontrer que l'opposition est restée
minoritaires par contre après tout ce
qui s'est passé ces jours ci au rpr et
là sans doute intérêt à faire la
démonstration qu'il est soutenu par
l'ensemble de sa majorité
d'ailleurs il semble bien que malgré les
critiques qui seront faites la semaine
prochaine le groupe
rpr dotera dans son ensemble de façon
positive si bien que l'on pense que
mercredi prochain le gouvernement
autorisera monsieur bara poser la
question de confiance et cela quelques
heures seulement avant qu'ils montent à
la tribune
du côté des partis politiques de gauche
la controverse se poursuit ainsi
monsieur jean epstein qui était candidat
aux élections pour le parti communiste
dans le 5e arrondissement de paris et
qui est l'un des historiens du parti
dresse aujourd'hui dans les colonnes de
notre confrère le monde
un bilan très négatif des récentes
élections pour jean epstein le pc a
réalisé cette année si l'on excepte les
élections de 1958 son plus mauvais score
depuis la guerre et ses mauvais
résultats sont dus au retard mis par le
parti communiste français à se
transformer et à prendre en compte les
problèmes nouveau causée par l'évolution
de la société française
demain le monde publiera la suite de ce
document de jean epstein
nous y reviendrons plus longuement avec
un commentaire d'alain duhamel demain
soir lors de notre journal de 20h
du côté des radicaux de gauche la chasse
à la présidence est ouverte ap michel
crépeau le député maire de la rochelle
qui a lancé son attention qui a annoncé
pardon son intention de postuler à la
succession de monsieur robert fabre
c'est monsieur maroselli qui a annoncé
aujourd'hui qu'il était lui aussi
candidat jusqu'à présent monsieur
maroselli était vice-président du
mouvement des radicaux de gauche
l'étranger nouveaux bruits de guerre
dans le sud est asiatique selon la radio
cambodgienne 20 à 25 mille soldats
vietnamiens ont participé la semaine
dernière à une nouvelle attaque dans la
vallée du mékong et verte nos peines
selon la radio khmer près de 600 soldats
vietnamiens aurait été tué lors de cette
offensive annexes ne confirment pas ces
informations
les dirigeants vietnamiens se déclare
toutefois peu près à négocier avec les
cambodgiens sur le problème des
frontières entre les deux pays
au proche orient un soldat israélien a
été tué cette nuit lors d'un accrochage
avec des fedayins à beyrouth la banlieue
sud-est de la capitale libanaise a été
sérieusement endommagée ce matin les
tirs de les plus forts les tirs
d'artillerie bien sûr on pose les
miliciens conservateur aux troupes
syriennes qui tentent semble-t-il
d'investir le quartier chrétien de
beyrouth
et puis aux états unis mauvaise nouvelle
pour le président carter qui n'a pas été
entendu du tout hier soir le chef de
l'état américain a évoqué à la radio et
à la télévision
le problème de la lutte contre la faim
aux etats unis résultat immédiat de
cette allocution la bourse a baissé et
le dollar sur le marché des changes
s'est effondré il faut dire qu'hier soir
le président carter n'a rien annoncé de
bien nouveau
alors il est critiqué ce matin dans la
presse d'outre-atlantique et sa
popularité a encore baissé pour la
première fois il y a plus d'américains
qui sont hostiles à la politique
économique menée par l'actuel président
kurde américains qui sont favorables
nul ne lui conteste son ardeur au
travail sa bonne volonté sa générosité
et pourtant les américains s'interrogent
un homme avec des idées louable mais
difficile à mettre en pratique
exemple les droits de l'homme tel
apparaît le profil du président
américain carter considère les dossiers
encore ouverts lorsque tout son
entourage
les croix clos constate le new york
times après la mise entre parenthèses de
la bombe à neutrons
le chef de l'exécutif américain veut
maintenir la détente l' équilibre avec
l'urss et c'est pourquoi il croit qu'en
se faisant le champion du désarmement il
pourra amener les soviétiques sur son
terrain et obtenir de leur part des
concessions
à washington on redoute que cette
attitude soit prise pour de la faiblesse
au mieux de l'investissement
carter est il un des six qui après avoir
ménagé béguines et la communauté juive
américaine est devenue aujourd'hui le
censeur le plus intransigeant de maynard
keynes bugs ainsi carter déconcerte et
intrigues non seulement l'europe mais
son opinion publique
indifférente aux récents voyages
planétaires de son président mais
préoccupé par les questions intérieures
le candidat carter avait promis des
réformes aux américains mais ces
derniers répondent au président carter
des réformes lui changer notre façon de
vivre ou non c'est pourquoi le projet
sur l'énergie restent lettre morte
malgré le gaspillage énergétique
qui coûtent une fortune à la nation
américaine sur ce point au moins
les propositions de carter sont justes
clairvoyante métro novatrice sans doute
pour son pays
l'écran pétrolier du texas et les lobbys
du congrès de lui ont fait comprendre
dans le même temps la presse américaine
peu habitué à l'indulgence reproche à
son président d'être mal conseillé ce
pays new brzezinski le successeur de
kissinger étant le plus souvent visés
trop de grands dessins et de concepts à
l'échelle du monde ils prennent le pas
sur les problèmes concrets de la nation
qui doivent être la préoccupation
majeure d'un président démocrate
surtout s'il veut être réélu cette mise
en garde est faite par la communauté
noire surtout dont les votes n'ont porté
au pouvoir et qui subit aujourd'hui les
incertitudes économiques
un dollar faible des importations qui
coûte cher les etats unis attendent des
initiatives de carter avant que
l'inflation ne fera pas la plante retour
au protectionnisme pur et simple
contrôle des prix ou création de
nouveaux emplois
on ne sait carter est il un activiste
sans doctrine ou un homme qui aurait
besoin du temps pour agir mais le chef
de l'état le plus puissant du monde
s'est-il que ses partenaires sans mérite
à moins que carter soit le seul à penser
que son pays entre dans une ère de
moindre puissance le moindre rayonnement
unique hypothèse qui justifierait son
difficile exercice du pouvoir avec
toutefois en filigrane cette question
qui est et que veut jimmy carter voilà
cette édition raccourci est maintenant
terminée dans 10 minutes sur antenne 2
bastia zurich c'est du football
allez les baskets et bonsoir